- [clears throat]
- Freddy, that is not how
an adult unpacks.
What are you doing
with the Constitution?
- Oh, I signed that.
- You should not have done that.
- Yeah,
there's some tricky stuff
about black people in there.
- Just find somewhere
safe to keep it.
Freddy.
This is your birth certificate.
- [soft laugh]
- Says that you're adopted.
- What?
- That means
your mother and father
aren't your mother and father.
- Mumu and Pupu?
- That means that
Lillian and Hortense
aren't your sisters.
- Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Wait, who's Hortense?
- Neither is Beatrice.
[dramatic music]
- I've been...
having sex with
a stranger my whole life?
- No, if Beatrice
isn't your sister,
that means
you didn't commit incest.
- Yes, I understand
what it means!
You don't have to rub it in.
- No, it's a good thing.
There is no scandal.
You're just...
a regular adulterer.
- It's a good thing?
- Yes, everyone in Washington
cheats on their wives
and vice versa.
- What?
- We'll announce the good news
right after the Olympics.